Jake:这一个
Jake: This one.
Jake:一个插头是吧
Jake: A plug, right?
Shure: 是的然后咱们弄几个锅
Shure: Yes, and then we need a few pots.
Shure: 是弄一个锅还是两个锅
Shure: Should we use one pot or two pots?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Shure: 一个锅
Shure: One pot.
Jake:有两个锅是吗
Jake: There are two pots, right?
Shure: 对有两
Shure: Yes, two.
Jake:这个不用垫
Jake: This one doesn't need a mat.
Lucia: 他们居然真的有运动过这个房子
Lucia: They actually exercised in this house.
Shure: 个锅那就用一个这个吧先
Shure: Then let's use this one first.
Shure: 用两个锅
Shure: Use two pots.
Jake:一个不用电
Jake: One doesn't need electricity.
Jake:就一个用电是吧
Jake: Only one needs electricity, right?
Shure: 底下还有一个不用电的
Shure: There's another one that doesn't need electricity.
Jake:咱没那么多差异
Jake: We don't have that many differences.
Shure: 这气好像不是那么多问题
Shure: The gas doesn't seem to be much of a problem.
Shure: 应该也不大
Shure: It shouldn't be a big deal.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 冰箱的电源吗
Lucia: Is this the power for the fridge?
Jake:可以用对
Jake: Yes, it can be used.
Jake:对但是插墙上就行
Jake: Yes, just plug it into the wall.
Jake:Holly
Jake: Holly.
Jake:看一看还有看还有多少
Jake: Take a look and see how much is left.
Alice:这个叉子
Alice: This fork...
Shure: 这个插座上面
Shure: This outlet above...
Alice:上面插排插插排插排插插排
Alice: Plug strip, plug strip, plug strip, plug strip.
Shure: 对这个插座上面
Shure: Yes, this outlet above.
Shure: 插排插插排
Shure: Plug strip, plug strip.
Alice:会不会有安全隐患
Alice: Will there be any safety hazards?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Lucia: 不会不会
Lucia: No, no.
Shure: 死不了放心真的
Shure: It won't be fatal, trust me.
Jake:没有这个大家都是这么火的
Jake: No, everyone does it this way.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 都已经如此生活30年了
Shure: We've been living like this for 30 years.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事这个不会的啦这个没问题的
Lucia: It's fine, it won't be a problem, really.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake:外边都是这么搞
Jake: Everyone does it this way outside.
Jake:并且我们这个是民牌插足
Jake: Besides, this is a trusted brand plug.
Alice:公牛是吗
Alice: Is it a bull?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:看到公牛我放心了
Alice: I feel relieved seeing the bull.
Shure: 然后就是坐这的同学稍微注意一些
Shure: So, everyone sitting here, please be a bit careful.
Tasha: 哈哈由我来进行一个开箱仪式吗
Tasha: Haha, am I the one hosting the unboxing ceremony?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 开箱的工作交给你了
Lucia: The unboxing task is yours.
Shure: 这白菜洗没洗呢
Shure: Has this cabbage been washed?
Lucia: 我负责取快递你负责开箱
Lucia: I'll pick up the package, you do the unboxing.
Alice:还没呢
Alice: Not yet.
Shure: 那要不洗洗一下子
Shure: Then, why don't we wash it real quick.
Alice:确实得洗
Alice: It definitely needs washing.
Alice:金针菇啥的也得洗一下
Alice: The enoki mushrooms and all that need washing too.
Alice:这种也得过一下
Alice: This kind needs a rinse as well.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:喂你好
Jake: Hello, hello.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Aha.
Alice:没洗手
Alice: Didn't wash hands.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 谢谢
Shure: Thanks.
Shure: 虽然没洗手
Shure: Even though you didn't wash your hands.
Shure: 但是不干不净
Shure: But still, dirty things...
Shure: 喝了有病
Shure: Drinking it makes you sick.
Tasha: 他这个
Tasha: This one...
Jake:我怎么知道我订单尾号是什么
Jake: How would I know my order's last digits?
Tasha: 感觉像诈骗
Tasha: Feels like a scam.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:不是不是订单尾号快递
Jake: No, it's not the order's last digits, it's the package.
Tasha: 什么时候吃晚饭
Tasha: When are we having dinner?
Lucia: 快
Lucia: Soon.
Shure: 打算在群里喊一下
Shure: Planning to announce it in the group.
Shure: 回家吃饭了
Shure: Time to go home for dinner.
Jake:没吧没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no, no.
Alice:可以再来一个吗
Alice: Can I have another one?
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 没事不是每个人都要吃到一个
Tasha: It's fine, not everyone needs to have one.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 啊这个能至于
Tasha: Ah, is this really necessary?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Huh?
Alice:我也觉得
Alice: I think so too.
Alice:因为他没有被压
Alice: Because it wasn't pressed down.
Shure: 啊稍微稍微冲一下
Shure: Ah, just rinse it a bit.
Shure: 虽然这应该是干净的
Shure: Although it should be clean.
Shure: 其实我想问
Shure: Actually, I wanted to ask...
Tasha: 其实我想问这个
Tasha: Actually, I wanted to ask about this...
Alice:嗯你说什么
Alice: Hmm, what did you say?
Tasha: 那个瓦斯罐应该装在哪
Tasha: Where should the gas canister be placed?
Shure: 装完装进去了
Shure: It's already installed.
Tasha: 装进去吧
Tasha: Install it then.
Tasha: 嗯行
Tasha: Okay, fine.
Shure: 我宿舍就有
Shure: I have one in my dorm.
Shure: 一个非非常不安全
Shure: It's really unsafe.
Alice:真牛逼
Alice: That's impressive.
Tasha: 我没有
Tasha: I don't have one.
Shure: 大家不要学
Shure: Don't try this at home, everyone.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 也可以烧水的哦
Shure: You can also use it to boil water.
Shure: 电水热水壶
Shure: An electric kettle.
Tasha: 月饼
Tasha: Mooncakes.
Shure: 还在楼下
Shure: They're still downstairs.
Tasha: 他们还有3个人是吧
Tasha: They still have three people, right?
Alice:我们学校前一段还着火了
Alice: There was a fire at our school recently.
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why is that?
Jake:用擦板吃火锅
Jake: Using a whiteboard to eat hotpot.
Alice:嗯有人吸烟
Alice: Hmm, someone was smoking.
Alice:哦这好像不让说的
Alice: Oh, we probably shouldn't say that.
Alice:无所谓哈哈
Alice: It's fine, haha.
Alice:没关系啊
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 关系没事他会把这段删掉的哈
Lucia: It's fine, they'll edit this part out, haha.
Jake:鬼笑不让说
Alice:不删也行无所谓
Alice: It's okay if they don't edit it out.
Shure: 有人逼逼哈哈哈
Shure: Someone's blabbering, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 第一
Tasha: First...
Lucia: 那我给你手动做音效
Lucia: Then I'll make the sound effects manually for you.
Shure: 然后他在逼逼的时候他逼逼的哈哈
Shure: And when he's babbling, he's just babbling haha.
Lucia: 你现在说吧
Lucia: You can talk now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈咪哈哈
Lucia: Haha, mi haha.
Alice:哈哈咦
Alice: Haha, yi.
Alice:无所谓这个
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Lucia: 我们学校之前也有过但好像是电动车
Lucia: Our school had something like that before, but it was an electric vehicle.
Alice:然后那个救护车开到楼下了
Alice: And then the ambulance came downstairs.
Alice:我还在睡觉
Alice: I was still sleeping.
Alice:完全没有听到
Alice: I didn't hear a thing.
Alice:他们在群里一直在吵我们要不要跑
Alice: They were arguing in the group chat about whether to run or not.
Alice:要不要跑
Alice: Should we run or not?
Alice:没有听到声音
Alice: Didn't hear any sound.
Jake:所以也没跑
Jake: So no one ran.
Lucia: 大家精神状态都很稳定吗
Lucia: Is everyone mentally stable?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:小的不用跑
Alice: The small ones don't need to run.
Alice:大的跑不了
Alice: The big ones can't run.
Alice:洗菜
Alice: Washing vegetables.
Jake:鼓手是
Jake: The drummer is...
Jake:就是是吧
Jake: That's right, isn't it?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Alright, alright.
Jake:打击乐手
Jake: The percussionist.
Alice:这点有餐盘啥的吗
Alice: Are there any plates here?
Alice:还是楼下有
Alice: Or are they downstairs?
Tasha: 这好像也有
Tasha: There seems to be some here too.
Alice:洗一下吧
Alice: Let's wash them.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice:这个不用洗
Alice: This one doesn't need washing.
Lucia: sorry不是这个
Lucia: Sorry, not this one.
Jake:嗯你先上去跟大家对齐一下
Jake: Hmm, go up first and align with everyone.
Katrina: 今天给可可给你采了非常丰富的数据
Katrina: Today, we collected a lot of data for you, Keke.
Jake:然后就结束
Jake: Then we'll finish.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Katrina: 外景然后包括情感数据
Katrina: Outside scenes and also emotional data.
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Katrina: 情感文本
Katrina: Emotional texts.
Jake:是哪的陈展文本
Jake: Where is the exhibit text from?
Katrina: 今天这位提供的
Katrina: Provided by today's guest.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 进行一些情感语言分析吧
Katrina: Let's do some emotional language analysis.
Katrina: 还有一些小狗
Katrina: And there are some puppies too.
Jake:你的这是什么
Jake: What is this of yours?
Shure: 回来了
Shure: I'm back.
Jake:三颗钱还是什么
Jake: Is it three coins or what?
Katrina: 非常非常丰富
Katrina: Very, very rich in variety.
Jake:三三颗出伪金币吗还是
Jake: Are they counterfeit coins or what?
Katrina: 哈哈哈都有
Katrina: Hahaha, there's everything.
Jake:什么都有
Jake: There's everything.
Jake:很多是吧
Jake: A lot, right?
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:要火要火
Jake: It'll be popular.
Shure: 没人吧
Shure: There's no one, right?
Katrina: 哇团建的感觉
Katrina: Wow, feels like a team-building event.
Jake:一会开吃了再结束吧
Jake: Let's start eating and then wrap it up.
Jake:就是把这个都拆开
Jake: Just open all of this up.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure: 我们来来个同学帮我一下
Shure: Can a classmate help me out here?
Jake:开吃就
Jake: Start eating then.
Jake:来要干啥
Jake: Come on, what are we doing?
Shure: 直接倒到那里面
Shure: Just pour it all in there.
Alice:这啥玩意怎么洗不掉呢
Alice: What is this stuff? Why can't it be washed off?
Shure: 省得我一点一点接了是吧
Shure: So I don't have to do it bit by bit, right?
Katrina: 诶从哪搞两股啊
Katrina: Hey, where did you get two strands from?
Jake:哦哦走赶走
Jake: Oh, oh, let's go.
Shure: 然后这个拿着吧
Shure: Then hold this.
Katrina: 就有啊哦
Katrina: There's some, oh.
Shure: 别别让这个粘着那什么
Shure: Don't let it stick to that thing.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Alice:然我说这洗不掉
Alice: I told you it won't wash off.
Jake:你别碰他
Jake: Don't touch it.
Alice:这什么玩意
Alice: What is this stuff?
Jake:就这样就行了
Jake: Just leave it like this.
Lucia: 有就是有的菜叶子上它就
Lucia: Some vegetable leaves have it.
Jake:就没必要了
Jake: There's no need for more.
Lucia: 就长这样还是怎么回事
Lucia: Is it supposed to look like this?
Lucia: 我们家洗菜也是
Lucia: We also wash vegetables at home.
Jake:是没必要了
Jake: It's not necessary.
Lucia: 就是有时候这个东西它是洗不掉的
Lucia: Sometimes this stuff just won't wash off.
Alice:摸摸
Alice: Touch it.
Jake:倒个数据呗
Jake: Pour the data.
Lucia: 应该它就长这样
Lucia: It should look like this.
Alice:好像长上去了一样
Alice: It seems to have grown on it.
Jake:数据倒了
Jake: Data's poured.
Lucia: 对它就长这样
Lucia: Yes, it looks like this.
Alice:好你给我做个见
Alice: Okay, make me a certificate.
Alice:证啊
Alice: Please.
Lucia: 好放心吧
Lucia: Okay, don't worry.
Alice:放心吧我确实洗了
Alice: Don't worry, I really washed it.
Lucia: 他就长这样
Lucia: It looks like this.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 哇哦
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 这放放顶上
Shure: Put this on top.
Shure: 不然话我一会钻不过去
Shure: Otherwise, I can't get through later.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 我对我自己几斤几两非常有点逼数
Shure: I know exactly how much I weigh.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Lucia: 我踩着啥了刚才
Lucia: What did I step on just now?
Shure: 呦呦呦
Shure: Yo yo yo.
Lucia: 你小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
Lucia: 主要是别碰到接口什么的地方
Lucia: The main thing is not to bump into the connectors or anything.
Katrina:  没事擦一下吧
Katrina: It's okay, just wipe it.
Lucia: 呃楼上是不是没有抹布好像哎有
Lucia: Uh, there's no rag upstairs, oh wait, there is.
Tasha: 这个水明显少了
Tasha: This water is obviously less.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 没事我们一会拿那个开水直接补吧
Shure: It's okay, we can just refill it with hot water later.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Use Wahaha water.
Katrina: 先拿抹布擦
Katrina: First, use a rag to wipe it.
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh.
Jake:啊用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Yeah, use Wahaha water.
Tasha: 就是说他的水很健康的感觉
Tasha: It feels like their water is very healthy.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha:实验室用水
Tasha: Lab water.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I was just making stuff up.
Katrina: 想喝个饮料
Katrina: I want to have a drink.
Jake:本身我们还有一个环节
Jake: Actually, we have another segment.
Jake:就是给你们五六种这种矿泉水
Jake: We have five or six types of mineral water.
Jake:让你们去分
Jake: For you to distinguish.
Shure: 啊可以啊
Shure: Oh, sounds good.
Katrina: 这是你设计的某种游戏吗
Katrina: Is this some kind of game you designed?
Lucia: 然后呢谁先把这些水喝完谁是赢家吗
Lucia: So, whoever finishes the water first is the winner?
Jake:谁能分辨得出来
Jake: Whoever can tell them apart.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 万事俱备
Shure: Everything is ready.
Shure: 只他娘的欠东风
Shure: Just missing the final touch.
Shure: 东风是什么呢
Shure: What is the final touch?
Shure: 东风就是火锅底料
Shure: The final touch is the hot pot base.
Tasha: 火锅底料呢
Tasha: Where is the hot pot base?
Tasha: 那个那个所有的料的那个袋子
Tasha: The bag with all the ingredients.
Katrina: 在楼下
Katrina: It's downstairs.
Tasha: 哦对
Tasha: Oh right.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Is that so?
Tasha: 是不是还要拿一些
Tasha: Do we need to get more?
Tasha: 8个碗 8个碟
Tasha: Eight bowls and eight plates.
Tasha: 嗯碗有
Tasha: We have bowls.
Tasha: 但盘子不够
Tasha: But not enough plates.
Tasha: 咱就用小碗吧嗯
Tasha: Let's just use small bowls then.
Lucia: 因为他这的盘子都是那种大一点的
Lucia: Because all the plates here are a bit large.
Lucia: 而且好像没有8个
Lucia: And we don't have eight of them.
Lucia: 至少楼上没有
Lucia: At least not upstairs.
Lucia: 不过小碗已经都拿出来了
Lucia: But I already took out all the small bowls.
Tasha: 就拿碗吧
Tasha: Let's just use bowls then.
Lucia: 对然后那有3个是楼下洗过
Lucia: Yeah, and there are three that were washed downstairs.
Lucia: 我直接拿上来了
Lucia: I just brought them up.
Tasha: 一二三四五五个
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five bowls.
Lucia: 然后对然后
Lucia: And then,
Tasha: 再拿三个碗
Tasha: Get three more bowls.
Lucia: 呃池子里应该还有几个
Lucia: There should be a few more in the sink.
Lucia: 反正我刚把底下都拿出来了
Lucia: Anyway, I took out everything from downstairs.
Lucia: 我先去拿一下那个调料
Lucia: I'll go get the seasoning first.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 帮我把菜端过去
Tasha: Help me carry the dishes over.
Tasha: 吃饭也要开棚
Tasha: We need to set up the canopy even for eating.
Jake:iPhone
Jake: iPhone
Jake:今天比较富裕
Jake: Feeling a bit rich today.
Shure: 有有一个
Shure: There's one.
Jake:今天是富裕上
Jake: Today is a rich day.
Shure: 要变成纯清汤
Shure: It needs to become a clear soup.
Katrina: 这就一包啊
Katrina: This is just one pack?
Shure: 对这就一包
Shure: Yeah, just one pack.
Tasha: 一包不能拆成两包用吗
Tasha: Can't we split one pack into two?
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Tasha: 他这个是写3-5人吃
Tasha: It says it's for 3-5 people.
Katrina: 他这个你撕一下
Katrina: Just tear it open a bit.
Shure: 其实也不是不行
Shure: Actually, it's not impossible.
Katrina: 对他应该是一锅的量
Katrina: Yeah, it should be enough for one pot.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Katrina: 然后就分成两个半
Katrina: Then just split it into two halves.
Tasha: 我也撕开
Tasha: I'll tear it open too.
Shure: 我们我们吃辣的水平是什么样的
Shure: What's our spice tolerance like?
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Everyone?
Katrina: 我很能吃辣
Katrina: I can handle a lot of spice.
Shure: OK四个全
Shure: OK, four pieces then.
Shure: 下一个里
Shure: Let's go with that.
Katrina: 哈哈哈总有刁民想害朕
Katrina: Hahaha, there's always someone trying to mess with me.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 辣辣不死你
Shure: Spicy enough to burn you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 明天不用拍摄
Shure: No shooting tomorrow.
Shure: 大家都在厕所
Shure: Everyone will be in the bathroom.
Tasha: 那那就各分一半吧
Tasha: Then let's just split it in half.
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Oh boy.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 各分一半了
Tasha: Let's split it in half.
Shure: 行行行这就各分一半吧
Shure: Alright, alright, let's split it in half.
Katrina: 强制下班喽case
Katrina: Time to clock out early.
Tasha: 那这个火锅底料反正是4块
Tasha: So this hotpot base has four pieces.
Tasha: 不如一个里面下两块
Tasha: Why not put two pieces in each pot?
Shure: 就我一个人下两块
Shure: I'll put two pieces in mine.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sounds good.
Shure: 这哪到哪
Shure: Is that alright?
Shure: 撒撒嘴吧就是
Shure: Just sprinkle it around.
Katrina: 刚从成都回来
Katrina: Just got back from Chengdu.
Tasha: 一个是两
Tasha: One is two.
Tasha: 一个锅是下两块
Tasha: One pot is two pieces.
Tasha: 一个锅是下半袋
Tasha: One pot is half a bag.
Lucia: 啊下半袋的意思是
Lucia: Ah, does half a bag mean...
Lucia: 是这个里面少下一块吗
Lucia: Does it mean putting one less piece in?
Lucia: 啊OK OK那这个也是拆开放到这里面
Lucia: Ah, OK, OK, so we also open this and put it in here.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 那我就拆了
Lucia: Then I'll open it.
Tasha: 不要让两种味道混合
Tasha: Don't let the two flavors mix.
Shure: i missing you my honey
Shure: I miss you, my honey.
Shure: don t you
Shure: Don't you?
Lucia: 怎么只有这一锅水最多
Lucia: Why does this pot have the most water?
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 啊这怎么办
Tasha: Ah, what should we do?
Shure: 什么一袋
Shure: What one bag?
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong?
Tasha: 只有一袋
Tasha: Only one bag.
Shure: 什么一袋不行吧
Shure: What? One bag isn't enough.
Tasha: 我的建议是把这个袋子撕开
Tasha: My suggestion is to tear the bag open.
Tasha: 然后倒一半
Tasha: And pour out half.
Shure: 这无需撕开
Shure: There's no need to tear it open.
Shure: 说明他不应该撕开
Shure: It means it shouldn't be torn open.
Tasha: 那怎么办
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Shure: 小公鸡点到谁我就选谁好啊
Shure: Whoever the little rooster points to, I'll choose, alright?
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Tasha: 那这个锅的菌汤该有多么的孤单呀
Tasha: Then this pot's mushroom soup will be so lonely.
Tasha: 啊煮一半把它捞出来放这个锅里
Tasha: Ah, cook half and take it out, put it in this pot.
Shure: 哈哈哈流动料包
Shure: Hahaha, the flowing seasoning pack.
Lucia: 失策早知道两个锅当时应该买两包
Lucia: Bad planning, we should've bought two packs for two pots.
Shure: 哦你在切东西
Shure: Oh, are you cutting something?
Shure: 厕所有人吗
Shure: Is there someone in the bathroom?
Shure: anyone
Shure: Anyone?
Shure: come in
Shure: Come in.
Shure: 我要进来喽
Shure: I'm coming in.
Tasha: 妈呀真想踢
Tasha: Oh my god, I really want to kick.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好多预热啊哈哈哈
Lucia: So much warm-up, hahaha.
Jake:严谨
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿
Lucia: 3次握手才能确定
Jake:有啊有啊
Lucia: 正在进行握手
Lucia: 我觉得我们家网经常握手它就握不
Shure: 这只扔了
Lucia: 上了
Lucia: 十五秒抓把鸭肠
Shure: 我们那个河马的那些袋子拿一个
Shure: 然后当一个垃圾袋吧
Shure: 哎你就在那弄
Shure: 那你先弄着
Lucia: 盒马袋子还有吗
Lucia: 我去看看
Shure: 有吧应该
Lucia: 哎我把我手机又撂哪
Lucia: 哎算放那了
Shure: 我们
Shure: 放点电影看吧
Shure: Let's watch a movie.
Jake:拖过去了
Jake: It's been dragged over.
Jake:那你复制过去
Jake: Then copy it over.
Lucia: 我感觉用完了
Lucia: I feel like it's used up.
Jake:我们都是复
Jake: We're all copy...
Jake:你们都是复制的吗
Jake: Did you all copy it?
Jake:拖过去有的会消失
Jake: Sometimes dragging it over makes it disappear.
Jake:有的不消失
Jake: Sometimes it doesn't.
Lucia: 就你了
Lucia: It's up to you.
Jake:这你啥事啊
Jake: What's it got to do with you?
Jake:拖鞋啥事啊
Jake: What's up with the slippers?
Jake:应该拖过去是复制
Jake: Dragging it over should copy it.
Jake:你对
Jake: You're right.
Jake:但是为什么消失
Jake: But why does it disappear?
Jake:数据还在是吧
Jake: The data's still there, right?
Choiszt: 对就是硬盘里
Choiszt: Yeah, it's on the hard drive.
Jake:不过去没到成功
Jake: It didn't successfully transfer over.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:哈哈哈你还有几个
Jake: Haha, how many more do you have?
Choiszt: 那也不能导我这个卡一次
Choiszt: But it shouldn't crash my card.
Jake:到不了12点吃完这个10点
Jake: If we can't finish this by 12, let's aim for 10.
Jake:大概我们能拍到10点 10点半
Jake: We'll probably shoot until around 10 or 10:30.
Jake:然后就各玩各的
Jake: Then everyone can do their own thing.
Jake:什么工作剧组工作
Jake: What work, crew work?
Jake:我们其实最好有个场记
Jake: Ideally, we should have a script supervisor.
Jake:我一个没有计计划标注
Jake: Without someone marking the plan...
Jake:特别会容易很多
Jake: It would be much easier.
Jake:一个时间线
Jake: A timeline.
Jake:就是没有戴眼镜的人
Jake: Like, someone without glasses...
Jake:你们就是比方说18的电
Jake: You know, for example, 18 minutes of electricity...
Jake:18分到什么什么
Jake: 18 minutes to something something...
Jake:然后谁就足够了
Jake: And then whoever, that's enough.
Jake:S r 就录够了这种东西
Jake: S R records enough of this stuff.
Jake:今晚就可以开始
Jake: We can start tonight.
Jake:今晚可以迭代一下的
Jake: We can iterate tonight.
Jake:你第一视角
Jake: Your first perspective...
Jake:呃如果有一个场对
Jake: If there's a scene...
Jake:如果有一个场地
Jake: If there's a location...
Jake:就是说他一直就是一直跟着嘛
Jake: Someone just follows along continuously...
Jake:然后一个人就够
Jake: And one person is enough.
Jake:他们自己记不住的
Jake: They can't remember themselves.
Jake:特别是这种准确的时间
Jake: Especially the exact time.
Jake:第二天第二天
Jake: The second day, the second day...
Jake:走上了正轨
Jake: Things got on track.
Jake:第一天尼玛了
Jake: The first day was a mess.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:这你妈后来一天我好歹是把眼睛搞定了
Jake: That first day, at least I got my eyes sorted out.
Jake:至少是一个第一视角数据
Jake: At least we had first-person data.
Jake:这比较稳定
Jake: That was stable.
Jake:第三视角确实有点
Jake: Third person was kinda...
Jake:整不整不过来
Jake: Couldn't quite manage it.
Jake:眼睛好导眼镜
Jake: Eyes, good, guide the glasses.
Jake:眼睛眼睛
Jake: Eyes, eyes...
Jake:也四台啊
Jake: There are four sets.
Jake:一人一台
Jake: One for each person.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Jake:我靠我不
Jake: Damn, I can't...
Jake:哈哈哈我倒23台
Jake: Hahaha, I have 23 sets.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:你说什么样的我们
Jake: You said what kind of...
Jake:心理活动
Jake: Psychological activities...
Jake:嗯我们可能挑一些片段出来
Jake: Hmm, we might pick some clips.
Jake:就是
Jake: Just
Jake:应该是这个视频里面大概有这么一些
Jake: There should be some parts in this video.
Jake:这个就是场务那个比较重要吧
Jake: This is kind of important for the scene.
Jake:就是可能有一段单独
Jake: Maybe there's a standalone part.
Jake:有一段是一些高光时刻你们频繁的去
Jake: There's a section with some highlights you frequently go to.
Jake:然后有一些可能没那么多
Jake: And some parts maybe not as much.
Jake:这个数据确实挺挺新的
Jake: This data is really quite new.
Jake:但是很他妈的那个
Jake: But it's so damn...
Choiszt: 确实
Choiszt: Indeed.
Jake:有点想睡觉哈哈哈
Jake: Makes you kind of sleepy, hahaha.
Jake:那人齐了吗
Jake: Is everyone here?
Jake:撸狗的人回来了
Jake: The dog walkers are back.
Jake:你们还有多少
Jake: How much more do you have?
Jake:安与安康鱼收了
Jake: The An and Ankang fish are collected.
Jake:20分钟 20分钟下来
Jake: 20 minutes, 20 minutes down.
Jake:那没问题
Jake: That’s fine.
Jake:还有一个小时呗
Jake: One more hour, right?
Jake:我一台电脑23台一晚上
Jake: I used one computer for 23 hours in one night.
Jake:为什么是23呢
Jake: Why 23?
Jake:15+621对吧
Jake: 15 plus 6 plus 2 plus 1, right?
Lucia: 啊哈我再看一眼
Lucia: Ah, let me check again.
Jake:你在用卡了40G
Jake: You've used 40G on the card.
Jake:40借100有人在用吗
Jake: 40 out of 100, is anyone using it?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Choiszt: 每天晚上就CTR的时候
Choiszt: Every night during CTR time.
Jake:哦哦断了
Jake: Oh, oh, it got disconnected.
Choiszt: 断了然后你睡着了我就记了
Choiszt: It got disconnected and then you fell asleep, so I recorded it.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:这
Jake: This
Jake:买的是吧
Jake: You bought it, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈你就不睡觉
Jake: Hahaha, you just don't sleep.
Tasha: 哦这边加的是开水
Tasha: Oh, here we add hot water.
Shure: 所以他开水加的多一点
Shure: So he adds a bit more hot water.
Jake:哎你们手机上面有的微信吗
Jake: Hey, do you guys have WeChat on your phones?
Jake:那行那一块一块的记
Jake: Alright, then we can note it down step by step.
Jake:其实今天就可以开始
Jake: Actually, we can start today.
Jake:就刚刚刚刚就可以开始
Jake: We could have started just now.
Jake:大概你们几点去
Jake: About what time are you guys going?
Jake:去撸狗了
Jake: To play with the dogs?
Jake:哈哈哈一秒就忘
Jake: Hahaha, I forgot in a second.
Jake:现在还是几
Jake: What time is it now?
Jake:大概就是16
Jake: It's about 16 o'clock.
Jake:开个o型开个
Jake: Open an O-shape.
Jake:哎不用不用点手机上面
Jake: Hey, no need, just use your phone.
Jake:好刚刚充电一不小心碰到了这个
Jake: Oops, I accidentally touched this while charging.
Jake:然后我就不敢动就踩到地雷了
Jake: Then I didn't dare to move, like stepping on a landmine.
Jake:就是那个键
Jake: It was that button.
Jake:电源键就按下去了
Jake: I accidentally pressed the power button.
Jake:我要弹起来就击了你知道吧
Jake: If I release it, it’ll explode, you know?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:找江东亚过来帮我把这个钱退了
Jake: Get Jiang Dongya to help me get a refund.
Jake:然后成功
Jake: And it worked.
Jake:哎现在设备够了很够
Jake: Now we have enough equipment, more than enough.
Choiszt: 可以
Choiszt: Okay.
Jake:完全态现在是完整
Jake: It's complete now.
Choiszt: 想志愿者不是完整体
Choiszt: Volunteers are not in full form.
Jake:但是常务两个也很多
Jake: But there are many in charge.
Choiszt: 正好好几个
Choiszt: Just the right number.
Jake:副局长今天是个副局长
Jake: Today we have a deputy director.
Jake:前面两个
Jake: Two in front.
Jake:我靠他妈敢死队哈哈哈
Jake: Damn, they’re like a suicide squad, hahaha.
Jake:仿真的安全
Jake: Safety simulation.
Jake:哦他给你钱
Jake: Oh, he gave you the money.
Jake:就就
Jake: Just...
Choiszt: 帮我想个办法
Choiszt: Help me think of a solution.
Alice:上去吃饭
Alice: Let’s go eat.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:BTNT和DACT这不是一个吗
Jake: BTNT and DACT, aren’t they the same?
Jake:没有区别
Jake: No difference.
Jake:这两个都没有选项
Jake: Both have no options.
Jake:就就没有区别
Jake: There’s no difference.
Jake:一款Dewix的这个投稿
Jake: A submission from Dewix.
Jake:都很傻逼没有选项
Jake: All stupid, no options.
Jake:他搞什么
Jake: What is he doing?
Alice:上去吃饭了
Alice: Let's go eat.
Jake:好好好说说什么
Jake: Alright, alright, what do you want to say?
Jake:哦哦哦行行场场机场机
Jake: Oh, oh, okay, airport, airport
Jake:我艾特你们一下啊
Jake: I'll tag you guys
Choiszt: 吃饭能记点啥
Choiszt: What can you remember about eating?
Jake:哎就你就你
Jake: Hey, just you, just you
Jake:就记一下几点再几点再吃饭
Jake: Just remember what time and then eat again
Jake:对就行了啊
Jake: Yeah, that's it
Shure: 开饭了
Shure: Dinner's ready
Shure: 可以吃了
Shure: You can eat now
Alice:叫了嗯但是无动于衷
Alice: I called, but there was no reaction
Shure: 笑了吗OK
Shure: Did you smile? Okay
Jake:基本都是
Jake: Basically, it's all
Jake:一直都是
Jake: Always like this
Jake:这个这个不用啊
Jake: This one, no need
Jake:这个也可以记
Jake: This one can be noted too
Shure: 喝喝
Shure: Drink, drink
Shure: 就是橙汁加朗姆酒
Shure: It's just orange juice with rum
Shure: 好像橙汁不够
Shure: Seems like there's not enough orange juice
Shure: 你其实对你们都喝不出来什么味
Shure: Actually, you guys can't taste much
Lucia: 啊太小看人了吧
Lucia: Ah, you're underestimating us
Shure: 选个片吧选个片吧
Shure: Pick a movie, pick a movie
Shure: 别让我的大脸在这地方待着
Shure: Don't let my big face stay here
Shure: 太太可怕了
Shure: That's too scary
Tasha: 是一个独立的国家
Tasha: It's an independent country 政治问题
Alice:为什么还是这个龙啊
Alice: Why is it still this dragon?
Tasha: 还是这局
Tasha: Still this round
Shure: 这是我iPad壁纸
Shure: It's my iPad wallpaper
Jake:啊这个能剥吗
Jake: Ah, can this be peeled?
Tasha: 什么这个能播吗
Tasha: What? Can this be broadcasted?
Jake:这个能剥吗
Jake: Can this be peeled?
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 这为什么不能播
Tasha: Why can't this be broadcasted?
Shure: 你还帮忙监督着是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you helping supervise? Haha
Tasha: 哦刚刚那段话吗
Tasha: Oh, that part just now?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know
Shure: 我也很开心
Shure: I'm happy too
Shure: 因为我有酒喝
Shure: Because I have booze to drink
Lucia: 没事就算橙汁用完了
Lucia: It's okay, even if we're out of orange juice.
Lucia: 咱还有可乐
Lucia: We still have cola.
Shure: 这个兑可乐好喝吗
Shure: Does this taste good mixed with cola?
Lucia: 自由古巴
Lucia: Cuba Libre.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Lucia: 自由古巴的传统兑法吗
Lucia: It's the traditional mix for Cuba Libre.
Tasha: 这是一道裂痕
Tasha: There's a crack.
Lucia: 这不是老母加可乐
Lucia: This isn't rum and cola.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:你这
Alice: Look at this.
Alice:你这屏幕裂了吗还是膜
Alice: Is your screen cracked or is it the protector?
Tasha: 不是膜
Tasha: It's not the protector.
Tasha: 什么时候开饭
Tasha: When are we eating?
Jake:可以开了是吧
Jake: Is it time to start?
Shure: 可以开始了
Shure: Yeah, we can start.
Shure: 其实摆起来吧咱们
Shure: Actually, let's set it up.
Alice:碗没拿过来
Alice: We didn't bring the bowls.
Jake:那就摆起来
Jake: Then let's set it up.
Jake:摆起来开
Jake: Set it up and start.
Shure: 然后把这个机器停了吧
Shure: Then let's turn off this machine.
Shure: 别别弄坏了
Shure: Be careful not to break it.
Jake:开
Jake: Start.
Jake:这个开完就结束录制
Jake: Once we start, we'll finish recording.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Jake:开把摆起来
Jake: Start and set it up.
Shure: 到时候没喝完的都得带回去
Shure: Whatever we don't finish drinking, we'll have to take home.
Tasha: 哦然后又不不不录了就开始正正哦
Tasha: Oh, then we won't record anymore and start for real.
Jake:然后就不录对对对
Jake: Then we won't record, right.
Alice:啊蚂蚁爬上来了
Alice: Ah, ants are climbing up.
Alice: 去死
Alice: Die!
Lucia: 把这个不要了
Lucia: Get rid of this.
Jake:这怎么开
Jake: How do you open this?
Jake:这叫刀划吗
Jake: Is this called cutting?
Jake:有刀吗
Jake: Is there a knife?
Lucia: 刀在那
Lucia: The knife is over there.
Jake:哎在哪
Jake: Huh, where?
Lucia: 那
Lucia: There.
Jake:有有刀是吗
Jake: There's a knife, right?
Katrina:  有
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 我还没没确定坐那
Shure: I still haven't decided where to sit.
Jake:我快了我快了
Jake: I'm almost done, almost done.
Shure: 橙汁不够了
Shure: We're out of orange juice.
Shure: 可能有点浓
Shure: It might be a bit strong.
Shure: 啊可以往里兑氧和毒
Shure: Ah, we can dilute it with oxygen and poison.
Nicous: 这个
Nicous: This one.
Lucia: 这个也开了吧要不
Lucia: Should we open this one too?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Choiszt: 合适特别合适
Choiszt: It's perfect, really perfect.
Jake:8个人两个过合适吧
Jake: Two pots for 8 people, right?
这好紧
It's really tight.
Lucia: 特别合适
Lucia: It's perfect.
Choiszt: 我觉得8个锅
Choiszt: I think 8 pots.
Lucia: 这这好紧啊
Lucia: This, this is really tight.
Jake:看你直播
Jake: Watching your live stream.
Lucia: 啊好
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 谢谢我看看有啥人能直接撕的
Lucia: Thanks, let me see if there are any that can be torn open directly.
Shure: 我们看点什么
Shure: What are we watching?
Lucia: 这是不能撕开啊
Lucia: This one can't be torn open.
Shure: 我们看点啥
Shure: What are we watching?
Lucia: 这能撕开耶
Lucia: This one can be torn open.
Tasha: 是你们3个人的绿豆糕
Tasha: These are your three green bean cakes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 因为你们三个当中不在
Lucia: Because among the three of you, someone wasn't there.
Tasha: 呃你猜
Tasha: Uh, guess.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 可以试
Lucia: You can try.
Jake:这是一个好问题
Jake: That's a good question.
Jake:一款可以问PUA
Jake: It's one you can ask PUA.
Lucia: 虾滑就下的时候再撕吧
Lucia: Tear open the shrimp when you're about to cook it.
Lucia: 呃这这这咋放呀
Lucia: Uh, how do we put this?
Jake:这个也可以撕
Jake: This one can be torn open too.
Jake:这个怎么
Jake: How about this one?
Lucia: 这是那个豆皮啥的应该
Lucia: This is the tofu skin, I think.
Nicous: 我没有
Nicous: I don't have it.
Shure: 腾讯会员
Shure: Tencent membership.
Shure: 我有没有来着
Shure: Do I have it?
Jake:我来撕
Jake: I'll tear it open.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 咱为啥买了两个毛肚哎呦妈
Lucia: Why did we buy two sets of tripe? Oh my god.
Shure: 经典搞笑是吧
Shure: Classic comedy, right?
Alice:这撕了吗
Alice: Did you tear this?
Shure: 吓得我特烦恼
Shure: I'm so nervous.
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Ah
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Tasha:撕了
Tasha: It’s torn.
Lucia: 撕了撕了
Lucia: It's torn, it's torn.
Lucia: 但是它里面还有个袋子
Lucia: But there's another bag inside.
Jake:随便看看
Jake: Just take a look.
Jake:这段不录你爱怎么
Jake: We’re not recording this part, do whatever you want.
Lucia: 我知道外面这层撕了
Lucia: I know the outer layer is torn.
Jake:哎不对
Jake: Hey, wait.
Lucia: 里面那可能是我也不知道它啥意思
Lucia: I don't know what the inner one is for.
Jake:有一圈摄像头在录
Jake: There are cameras recording.
Lucia: 下的时候再撕还是什么吧
Lucia: Maybe tear it when taking it out or something.
Shure: 就是要放能播的是吗
Shure: So we need to put what can be broadcasted, right?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it’s okay.
Jake:go Pro
Jake: Go Pro.
Jake:放脸能播的
Jake: Show the face that can be broadcasted.
Jake:go Pro还在拍
Jake: The Go Pro is still recording.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Lucia: 真真的吧
Lucia: Really?
Tasha: 素毛肚吧
Tasha: It’s vegetarian tripe, right?
Jake:就是你你在塞博吃火锅
Jake: You know, you’re eating hot pot in cyber.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice:洗一下吗这个
Alice: Should we wash this?
Lucia: 不知
Lucia: Not sure.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Shure: 还洗一下吗
Shure: Should we wash it?
Alice:9个呢
Alice: There are 9.
Shure: 不干不净
Shure: It's unclean.
Shure: 吃了没病
Shure: Eating it won't make you sick.
Lucia: 我哎
Lucia: Oh, come on.
Lucia: 我以为他这种包装都是直接吃的嘞
Lucia: I thought it was ready to eat from the package.
Lucia: 不了解
Lucia: No idea.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 给大家表演一个人类洗毛肚啊
Shure: Let me show you how humans wash tripe.
Jake:可以记下来
Jake: You can note that down.
Lucia: 啊你真的系了
Lucia: Oh, you really washed it.
Jake:你知道
Jake: You know
Tasha: 把这个包
Tasha: Take this bag
Lucia: 记一些高光时刻是
Lucia: Remembering some highlights is
Tasha:这个没有吗
Tasha: Don't we have this one?
Alice:这个没有吗
Alice: Don't we have this one?
Tasha: 所以我们决定两边一起共用
Tasha: So we decided to share both sides
Shure: 经典不知道看什么时候
Shure: Classic, I don't know when to watch
Shure: 就看点夏洛特烦恼
Shure: Let's watch some "Goodbye Mr. Loser"
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Jake:迭代一下
Jake: Iterate
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:还没迭代
Jake: Not iterating yet
Jake:迭代迭代
Jake: Iterate, iterate
Jake:多换几个
Jake: Change a few more
Jake:人气就一直很嗨
Jake: The popularity is always high
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:开空调吗
Jake: Turn on the air conditioner?
Choiszt: 开吧
Choiszt: Turn it on
Lucia: 我直接我建议我直接用碗喝水了
Lucia: I'll just, I suggest I drink water directly from a bowl
Lucia: 所以一会就用这个碗吃
Lucia: So later I'll eat with this bowl
Jake:遥控器在哪啊空调
Jake: Where's the air conditioner remote?
Lucia: 嗯好问题
Lucia: Hmm, good question
Alice:是不在那个沙发上那个是吗
Alice: Isn't it on that sofa?
Lucia: 黑色这是吗
Lucia: The black one, is it this one?
Tasha: 白色
Tasha: White one
Shure: 黑色是电视
Shure: Black one is for the TV
Lucia: OK
Alice:是不是开空调的时候放下去了还是
Alice: Did we put it down when we turned on the air conditioner or
Shure: 这也不是
Shure: This isn't it either
Shure: 这是那什么的
Shure: This is for something else
Jake:放下去了吗
Jake: Did we put it down?
Shure: 这呢这呢
Shure: Here it is, here it is
Shure: 这呢我放这了
Shure: Here it is, I put it here
Jake:瞅一瞅去找一找啊
Jake: Take a look, go find it
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Jake:这个像确实像
Jake: This looks like it
Shure: 就这就是
Shure: This is it
Lucia: what's this
Lucia: What's this?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Shure: 谁调到22度我妈妈在家不揍你
Shure: Who set it to 22 degrees? If my mom was home, she wouldn't beat you up.
Shure: 26度调好了
Shure: Set it to 26 degrees, done.
Jake:保护地球
Jake: Save the Earth.
Jake:人人有责哈哈哈
Jake: Everyone's responsibility, hahaha.
Shure: 就是这你说录进去多不好啊
Shure: Seriously, you think it's good to record this?
Shure: 我们还用空调
Shure: We're still using the AC.
Shure: 他真的一点听不到哎
Shure: He really can't hear a thing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们仿佛在看默剧一样
Shure: Hahaha, it's like we're watching a silent movie.
Jake:嚯这确实经典
Jake: Whoa, this is classic.
Jake:来我们干个杯
Jake: Come on, let's have a drink.
Jake:就come杯
Jake: Just a drink.
Jake:come杯
Jake: A drink.
Jake:有有杯子吗
Jake: Do we have any cups?
Alice:多了
Alice: Plenty.
Jake:好好杯子
Jake: Great, cups.
Shure: 应该喝不出来什么
Shure: Shouldn't taste like much.
Jake:我要把我爸把我茅台打上来
Jake: I'm going to bring up my dad's Maotai.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 那边一个这边一个
Shure: One there, one here.
Alice:这个车标
Alice: This car logo.
Lucia: 玛莎拉蒂
Lucia: Maserati.
Alice:他演了这个烧饼
Alice: He's playing the character Shaobing.
Lucia: 哦哈哈
Lucia: Oh, haha.
Jake:干杯吧
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 干杯
Shure: Cheers.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:对
Jake: Yep.
Lucia: ok啊那还行
Lucia: Okay, that's fine.
Lucia: 那我拿这玩意也不是那么突兀
Lucia: So holding this thing doesn't look too weird.
Jake:哈哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, indeed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢你哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you, haha.
Jake:来干杯
Jake: Come on, cheers.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's do it.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: eagle life票房大卖哈哈哈
Shure: Eagle Life, box office hit, hahaha.
Jake:来药房大卖
Jake: To a booming pharmacy.
Jake:哈哈哈大卖卖
Jake: Hahaha, a great success.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Ahahaha
Jake:点击百亿开源
Jake: Click to reach a billion hits
Shure: 希望点击百亿啊
Shure: Hope we get to a billion hits
Tasha: 这不是开源开源产品吗
Tasha: Isn't this open source?
Jake:开源产品吗
Jake: Open source product?
Jake:卖卖卖
Jake: Sell, sell, sell
Jake:对上万star
Jake: Yes, over ten thousand stars
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This is good
Jake:专业这个专业
Jake: Professional, this is professional
Shure: OK那我们stop recording
Shure: OK then we stop recording
Alice:老板有筷子吗
Alice: Boss, do you have chopsticks?
Jake:这是吗不是
Jake: Is this it? No
Alice:你的筷子呢
Alice: Where are your chopsticks?
Jake:十恶不露
Jake: Keep them hidden
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:对你不用场景
Jake: You don't need them for this scene
Shure: 有勺子吗
Shure: Do you have spoons?
Shure: 对咱没有勺子
Shure: Yeah, we don't have spoons
Shure: 怎么把这个麻将舀出来呢
Shure: How are we supposed to scoop this with a mahjong tile?
Jake:咱有有点勺子
Jake: We do have some spoons
Jake:有塑料勺子
Jake: We have plastic spoons
Jake:会画吗哈哈哈哈
Jake: Can you draw? Hahaha
Shure: 不会不会
Shure: No, no
Shure: 你这
Shure: You...
Jake:谢谢这是啥呀
Jake: Thanks, what is this?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my
Jake:自带美
Jake: Naturally beautiful
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's okay, it's okay
Jake:对对对谢
Jake: Yeah, yeah, thanks